يمثل اطلاق المخطط العام لمطار الملك
سلمان الدولي الجديد في الرياض جزءا مهما
من الاستراتيجيه الوطنيه للنقل والخدمات
اللوجستيه والمبادله الوطنيه لسلاسل
الامداد العالميه الداعمه لجهود السعوديه
في تنويع اقتصادها وتحويل الرياض الى احد
اكبر 10 اقتصادات للمدنين عالميه
[موسيقى]
انضم علينا في الاستديو الخبير في قطاع
طيران المهندس طارق العيد
من الرياض
وفي السعوديه
الامير محمد بن سلمان 1945
اعلان تسجيل قوي جدا على مدى عده مراحل
لمده اكثر من 30 سنه
الرياض
قوي بهالشكل وتصف بهذه الطريقه واحد متابع
مراقب
يعني هذا قطع الطيران مهتم ايضا في شيء
الاهميه اللي انت تشوفها فيه قبل الاعلان
هذا يعني اهميه الرياض الرياض اصلا احد
مدارج مطار الملك خالد الدولي في الرياض
حاليا المدرسه
تقريبا 25 متر يعتبر ما هبط الطائرات في
مطار الملك خالد الدولي في الرياض احد
المهابط او احد الخيارات لوكاله الطيران
او وكاله الفضاء الامريكيه ناسها لهبوط
الفضائي مطار الرياض ما هو الرياض هذا
اهميته ك- موقع استراتي اللي هو المطار
الملك خالد حاليا
اذا نظرنا الى مبادرات تعزيز مكانه الرياض
وجعل المملكه مركز لوجستي عالمي للنقل
الجوي
نرى ان اهميه وجود نافذه جويه
تربط الرياض بالعالم اهميه لا يمكن نقاش
حولها نهائيا وتقبل القسمه على اثنين لذلك
هذا هذه المبادره باستثمارات ضخمه جدا لم
يعني ارقامها تهدف لمضاعفه العدد
المسافرين الى سته اضعاف تتكلم عن 185
مليون مسافر 185 مليون مسافر بالارقام
الحاليه
المطار الملك خالد ومطار الملك سلمان
الجديد اكبر من مطار هيثرو في لندن ومطار
دبي ومطار الملك خالد في الوقت الراهن
الان 155 مليون مسافر هذه اهميه موقع
الرياض ان الرياض ممكن تطير انت اللي 70%
المطارات العالم في اقل من خمس ساعات
الاهميه هذه يعني راح تضعف لك زي ما جاء
في البيان ربط بين الشرق والغرب
همم انت انت هتقفز بعدد المسافرين لست
ضعاف تقريبا حركه الطائرات اليوميه حد
ضعفها بخمسه اضعاف حركه البضائع والكاربو
لان في معلومه ما تغيب عنك اخي نايف انه
80% من تريد العالمي يمر عبر المملكه
ومن خلال هذا المطار والمركز يعني هو ليس
مطار فقط بل هو مدينه مطار مدينه مدينه
على على شكل مطار من خلال هذا الموقع راح
تضاعف عدد الوظائف الا ثلاثه وثلاثه ونص
مليون طن ثمان سنوات
عشر اضعاف الارقام الحاليه انت راح ضاعف
عدد حركه الطائرات الى خمسه اضعاف يوميا
مقارنه من 211000 حركه في اليوم الى عفوا
211,000 حركه سنويه الى مليون حركه ممتاز
يعني ياخذني معك الى السؤال انه في ناقل
جديد سيعلن عنا همم قريبا حتى يمكن كان في
حديث من همم من فتره يعني قريب عن هذا
الجديد يكون في همم في الرياض بالاضافه
الى الاعلان مخطط العامله مطار الملك
سلمان الدولي في الرياض كيف تقرا مستقبل
الطيران في السعوديه هذا القطاع باختصار
لو سمحت
والمستقبل باذن الله مجرد ايام وسنوات
قليله ونوصل له باذن الله الرياض حتى تصبح
الخير رقم واحد لربط شرق الكره الارضيه
بغربها ستصبح الرياضيه الخيار رقم واحد
باذن الله مع هذه الخطط الطموحه لمن يريد
الانتقال من كوريا او اليابان او استراليا
من شرق الكره الارضيه الى غرب الى امريكا
مرورا
بالتزاوج مع وجود ناقل جوي همم متين كما
اعلن عنه في الايام السابقه اخذناها في
تصوري ان الرياء او حسب نوع الارقام يوم
امس انه 27 مليار ريال همم
في المملكه العربيه السعوديه وساهم في خلق
اكثر من ثلاث الاف وظيفه مباشره وغير
مباشره همم في في الرياض بعوائد اقتصادها
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
المهمه والقيمه في القطاع الطيران زي ما
يخص هذا المطار الجديد
هنا في الاستديو الخبير القطاع الطيران
للمهندس طارق العيد شكله المهندس الحب
حياكم